now the G20 Summit on the Indonesian
island of Bali has ended with a joint
declaration condemning the war in
Ukraine even though Russia itself is a
G20 member the summit's closing
statement said leaders denounce the war
despite some divisions among the group
Western leaders also met on the
sidelines of the G20 to discuss the
missile explosion on the Polish border
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz called
for a thorough investigation and warned
against drawing Hasty conclusions the
Indonesian president Joko Widodo who
played host to the G20 called the
incident in Poland regrettable
uh
DW's Brussels bureau chief Alexandra Von
Norman is in Bali and she told us more
about the outcome of the summit
well we know that during those
closed-door meeting U.S President Biden
informed brief his fellow leaders about
his conversations with Polish president
Duda and NATO chief stoltenberg he then
According to some sources here went on
suggesting that the blast in Poland was
probably caused by an anti-aircraft
missile fired by the Ukrainian forces to
intercept Russian rockets and that is
something that he also later indicated
when speaking with reporters and after
this close door meeting the leaders
released a statement saying that they
stand in full solidarity with Poland
that they would provide Poland with any
assistance needed to investigate this
incident and they also went on saying
that they are reaffirming their
solidarity with Ukraine and condemning
condemning recent attacks by the Russian
army on civilian Target in Ukraine and
you just have to imagine how the mood
was because the leaders were woken up in
the middle of night here in Bali and
inform about the incident in Poland so
all of them were shocked and worried so
it was generally a unified reaction from
the global leaders
well from the G7 and NATO leaders
present here in Bali but we of course
also heard from the Indonesian president
who stressed that this incident is
regrettable but of course that is
important now to stay calm the Chinese
statement went in a similar Direction
China said that it's now important to
exercise exercise restraint and to not
do anything to uh to escalate the
situation and that is also what the
German Chancellor stressed here saying
that it's important to establish all the
facts that also what the British prime
minister said here and of course
everyone is now calling for for all
parties to remain calm now the G20
leaders declaration has been approved at
the end of this Summit with a very clear
condemnation of Russia's war in Ukraine
now Russia is a member of the G20 why
did Russia agree to this text
was a very interesting question because
of course you would assume that Russia
would do anything to prevent the strong
condemnation of its war on Ukraine from
being included in the official document
and we put this question to officials to
Western officials here in Bali and they
told us that it was a success for the
Indonesian presidency of the G20 they
were reaching out talking to every
member of their G20 but they also
stressed that Russia was becoming
increasingly isolated here with more and
more emerging economies India for
instance being in favor of such a strong
statement so they assumed that in the
end Russia just didn't prevent this
statement from being published because
they didn't want to stand there totally
alone
reporting from Bali thank you so much
as their Summit in Bali wrapped up
earlier today G20 countries are vying to
calibrate the pace of interest rate
hikes in order to avoid spillovers
leaders warned there was the risk of
quote increased volatility in currency
moves that of course as the world
economy faces other crises including the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and surging
inflation a letter signed by members at
the end of the two-day meeting said that
G20 central banks are closely monitoring
the impact of price pressures
right let's get more from DW business's
Azure Pandey at the G20 uh Summit in
Bali ashitosh uh leaders warned
um how did the g21s G20 countries want
to work together when it comes uh um to
fighting inflation when even the
interest rate hikes in the US and the
European Union seem to be out of sync
well Chris that's a tricky thing to do
if you look at managing debt distress
that's more important that's what uh the
country were countries were talking
about the leaders were talking about uh
see the FED is going to do what it has
to and the likewise for ECB it's going
to do what it has to and the Mandate
primary mandate is to bring down prices
and they're not going to stop till the
prices start coming down and that in
result in return is going to boost the
dollar up and that's going to be painful
for those countries which owe a lot of
the debt in dollar terms uh so what can
be done so basically what uh can be done
is to manage the spillovers that could
be managed by say debt relief some sort
of debt negotiations restructuring and
that's where the G20 comes in
this summit's motto is recover stronger
recover together other than vying to
work together on inflation what are the
economic outcomes of this meeting
regarding the world economy briefly if
you could
like Chris you mentioned up front it was
a meeting that was dominated by
geopolitics the war in Ukraine uh 80 to
90 of the time that the leader spent
here was actually spent dealing with the
language of the war in Ukraine but they
still managed to take out some time to
talk about food and energy security that
was top an agenda as far as the host
Indonesia is concerned the president
Joko we really wanted the leaders to
discuss this this has been a pain point
for so many countries and uh fertilizer
shortage was one another topic that was
discussed so this was actually discussed
in great detail uh and uh that's what
the Indonesia was looking forward to
tws Pandey reporting from the G20 Summit
in Bali ashutosh thank you